hi there today we're looking at
fast and slow learning of recurrent
independent mechanisms
by kanika madan rosemary nanke
anirud goyal bernard shelkoff and
joshua benjo so this paper
on a high level proposes an update to a
previous paper
which was about recurrent independent
mechanisms
and the update it proposes is to learn
the individual parameters
of the different subsystems that
comprise
recurrent independent mechanisms at
different time scales
the idea behind recurrent independent
mechanisms
is that you have sub modules in a
reinforcement learning agent
that specialize on different sub tasks
that the agent has
to do and then you have sort of higher
level modules which are attention-based
modules
that select those sub modules and
decide how they communicate with each
other
as i said this paper here builds on that
and proposes to learn these higher level
parameters
at different time scales than the lower
level
parameters such that the higher level
units
can generalize to multiple
tasks and this helps you in environments
where you have to do
multiple tasks so we're gonna go over
this paper
and we're mostly also gonna go over what
recurrent independent mechanisms are
and as i already said it this paper
didn't doesn't introduce recurrent
independent mechanisms that's a previous
paper by
it has some overlap in authors
so keep this in mind as we go through it
if you're
specifically interested in recurrent
independent mechanisms i invite you to
go read
the previous paper will go over both
rem or ims and the update to it
in the end this paper demonstrates that
by
decoupling the learning you get benefits
in environments where this structure of
you know multi-task multi-objective is
given
it can generalize to unseen tasks
pretty well and on the other hand
i think for what this paper does right
here for the fact that it simply
proposes this
this update i don't i don't think it
does
enough to demonstrate really that this
is something worthwhile or
it doesn't analyze it enough i feel and
they also
call this what they're doing meta
learning which
i i i don't really agree to call this
meta learning
but you'll see for yourself we'll go
over the paper
and yeah bear with me so
as always if you like content like this
don't hesitate to
share it out and tell all your friends
about it
and tell me what you think in the
comments
they say in the abstract right here
decomposing knowledge
into interchangeable pieces promises a
generalization advantage
when there are changes in distribution
a learning agent interacting with its
environment is likely to be faced with
situations requiring
novel combinations of existing pieces of
knowledge
so the hypothesis here is that
if you are in an environment that has
sort of
different tasks inside of it that that
where the
environment itself changes so your
objective
changes as well then it might be helpful
to recombine old knowledge
and the the situation you have to have
in mind with this paper is
one of their core environments here is a
sort of a grid world environment and the
grid world environment is simply you
have this grid
and the agent occupies one cell right
here
maybe the agent is here and the agent
can sort of move
around here and do different actions and
there
there's going to be different things in
this environment so maybe there's like a
key
right here this is a key and maybe
there's like a door
over here and the agent will get
an instruction now the instruction in
this environment might be
get the key and
go to then go to the door then
go to the door okay so this might be the
instruction it
might actually always be the same
instruction in this particular
environment
but if you change the key and you change
the door
where they are that's already like
different tasks or
it's not it's not the the same
environment all the time you can also
vary the size of these
environments pretty easily so all these
tasks these different
tasks they share some underlying
structure
which is there's always kind of this
world and there's a key and there's a
door
and there might be a wall right here
so they all share this structure however
what exactly you have to do differs from
episode to episode you can also imagine
that there is
maybe i don't know maybe there's like an
orange here so there's an orange
right here and then the text instruction
will say
uh get or go
go eat the orange
so now the agent has to ignore the key
and the door and go to the orange right
and additionally so you can modulate
this a lot
additionally you can say okay the agent
maybe only sees
its surrounding maybe like this right so
the agent only sees
whatever is in front of it and a little
bit to the side
so it needs to sort of turn around and
explore
there's lots of variations the important
thing is that
there's an environment that has some
kind of over over
structure overarching structure and
there's different
tasks and each episode is sort of a new
task
that the agent needs to solve
now what happens if the agent here
is implemented in as in classic
reinforcement or deep reinforcement
learning as
one big box like one neural network
and then you perform your episodes and
you
update the neural network the parameters
of the neural network according to your
reward if you solve
one task your you will update according
to that task right so if you solve the
key the key door task let's
call it that then your neural network
all the parameters will be updated uh
with
respect to that task right the way you
train a neural network is
that you you change the parameters such
that your loss decreases
so you will train your neural network to
solve that task as well as possible
but now the task changes right then all
of a sudden it's get the orange
now all of a sudden this doesn't give
you a reward anymore right
and now the orange gives you a reward so
all the parameters you're going to
change in order to
serve this new task uh you know finding
the orange
but this is supposed to be like a little
light speck
i'm terrible at this i'm absolutely
terrible at this
um it's like an orange donut
um but you get what i i mean this
in general in the fields of like
lifelong learning and and multi-task
learning and so on
this is known as catastrophic forgetting
catastrophic forgetting
i don't even know why i bother to write
like no one can read anyway
so there is lots of work in preventing
catastrophic for getting in these types
of
situations and the way that this or
the previous paper the recurrent
independent mechanisms propose
to do that is let's not implement
our agent as one big box rather
let's implement it as a collection of
like little
sub modules and these little sub modules
they focus
on individual sub tasks okay
so a sub tasks might be find
go to somewhere okay with the somewhere
being a parameter that's then taken from
the
instructions um or maybe one one
parameter
specifically for recognizing the orange
okay
so now and the other one is for
recognizing the key
now if the instructions say go to the
key
the module that is recognizing the key
might become
active and the module that is um
that is for going somewhere might become
active and the combination of the two
might then get you to the key so in each
time
step the idea is let's only activate a
subpart
of these modules not all of them at the
same time
and now only these modules will be
active
because they are relevant for the
current tasks and then
only these modules will receive a
learning signal and not the other
modules okay the other modules will stay
fixed for that particular um
for that particular step on in time
and this makes sense if you if you think
about it right if
your module isn't relevant for the task
then it shouldn't receive a learning
update and that's how you
try to prevent catastrophic forgetting
so if this here
this module down here remembers to re or
can recognize the orange and right now
you're trying to find the key and get to
the door
then if you don't up if you do update
that module it will be in service
of the goal of finding the key and
getting to the door so it will forget
the orange
however if you decide no this module
isn't relevant for the current task
and then you prevent an update to it
then
it won't forget the orange it will only
come into life
once the task is actually about the
orange
and then of course you want the learning
signal
so that's the idea right here to prevent
catastrophic
forgetting i do have my doubts that
that is is so
like that that scales to because the
combinatorics
of catastrophic forgetting or rather
large and and therefore but
you know depending on how you factor the
independent things you need to do um
it it is a good idea okay so that's the
core idea
it is that instead of having this one
box you have a lot of small boxes
and now you do this right
these reinforcement learning problems
they're often implemented as like
recurrent networks and it's not a it's
not by chance that this thing is called
recurrent independent mechanisms
because each of these little boxes like
the big box would be
is a recurrent neural network so
the way that these things work is that
you have your different
your inputs which is frame by frame by
frame right
and the input goes through some sort of
an encoder
into a hidden state and
you do have your hidden state that's
from so the hidden state that the agent
itself carries this is kind of its
internal memory
and you use the input
frame of the game so this is frame one
this is frame two this is frame three
you use the input frame and your own
hidden state to produce the next hidden
state and you can easily
implement this with some sort of an lstm
right
and then you use that and that to
produce the next hidden state
so that's the normal way of how things
are done
now in the so that's if you just have
like an lstm
controller now if you have a recurrent
independent mechanism controller
then your hidden state will be
sort of a it will consist
of many hidden states so the hidden
state itself will be a collection of
hidden states
right and um so these are supposed to be
little vectors
and then the input comes in here and
then
only a subset is selected so maybe
this one and this one are selected
now the way that this works is
uh i shouldn't even draw one circle here
i should actually draw
four circles okay so you have
four lstm controllers and only two of
them are selected i'm going to tell you
how they're selected
in a second actually i'm going to tell
you right now
probably that's better so what what you
do
is you nah let's let's do that after
so you select two you deactivate the
other two
and the way you produce your next hidden
state is sorry
is simply you copy over
the hidden states of the deactivated
modules so you just
copy those over so they remain
and you would update
the hidden states of the modules that
you
selected so only those modules are
active
all right so
now yeah so that's
that's that and there is also a
communication step at the end
uh we'll we'll go into that here because
here's the
diagram so down here you see what i've
just
told you this is the system okay you
have to imagine there is the last frame
right here there is the next frame down
here
uh the frame and also the so that's the
observation and the instruction they go
through some sort of an
encoder which would also be the same
encoder up here
and down there
then there is the hidden state which is
here in blue so these are the
independent mechanisms wait that's the
wrong blue
so we have in this case four
four independent mechanisms those would
actually carry over
over time the state the internal state
of the agent
right and then at each time step
you have an output of a value head and a
policy head the method they use right
here is proximal
policy optimization as far as i
understand it
this is a variant on actor critic method
if you don't know about deep
reinforcement learning or proximal
policy optimization or actor critic
methods or why we need value and policy
heads
i invite you to go look that up that
it's fairly simple
it's a very basic algorithm uh where you
can do reinforcement learning
you can calculate a loss and then you
can back propagate
to these either to the encoder and also
to the to the parameters in the
recurrent cells here okay
so how do we decide which modules are
activated and which ones aren't
and that goes through an attention
mechanism
and that's what they call here input
attention
so input attention is the following
you have your input okay and
you do have uh the encoder for the input
which is like
maybe a some concoction some alchemic
concoction of neural network right
that gives you a vector like an
embedding of the input
now you go to your
little modules each of them will have a
hidden state
already and they get to do attention to
that input
so the input will emit keys and queries
now you can do this in multiple heads
but ultimately let's do
one vector okay so here is a key sorry
it will emit keys and values okay there
is a key
and it will also emit the value we can
we can just get
we can just do like say the value is the
input itself
if we do not have a
if we don't have uh multiple heads
but ultimately they emit keys and values
and
every single one of the uh
mechanisms emits some sort of a
query so in essence the
um the input outputs a a descriptor for
what it contains
right that's how you have to think about
attention and the
the each of the mechanisms outputs a
query
for what they would like to see so they
get to look
and at their hidden state and
they get to decide what kind of
information would i like to
read from the input or what it's more
like a filter
what kind of input is relevant to me so
the mechanism that cares about the
orange
it would output probably a query for
saying is there something orangey in the
input either in the instructions or
in the picture is there like something
about an orange there
and um the the the one
that cares about the key would obviously
say well
is there something about the key in
there but you can also imagine more
abstract things
and then the attention is computed via
inner product
and you can see here it's those two
mechanisms
that are closest in inner product to the
key and then only those two
get get uh selected for this particular
time step
and those get eliminated not eliminated
but
only the two on the right get to update
the hidden state
as you can see right here the ones
that are not selected they the
hidden state is simply carried over
whereas the ones that are selected they
actually get to do
computation and update their hidden
state
now at the end of the update of the
hidden state there
is a communication step so these are not
fully independent
they do get to communicate with each
other and
so they here they have a new hidden
state
and here they have an the old hidden
and now we get to communicate with each
other
and again um the way this works is
that every single one of them
processes the input actually so the
input goes through
all of them
all of these emit again a query
and sorry a key of them emit a vector
saying you know what did i get out of
this input
even the ones that were not selected
they emit some sort of information
and the ones that were activated they
get to emit
a query for what they would like to see
of the other modules and that's how you
get the intercommunication
right that's how you get to like higher
order independent mechanisms so you
could actually get a mechanism
for going somewhere and then
that mechanism would query sort of
another mechanism
that says well where do i need to go and
the other mechanism that
was like well i i know where to go
because the instructions said
uh find an orange and i'm the orange
module so i located the orange so they
get to communicate to
to each other so that there's going to
be attention
based communication where the active
modules
read from both the other active modules
and the in
active modules and then you go to the
next step and you repeat and then the
next step
it could be that different modules are
activated right
so these two attention mechanisms the
first one called the input attention
that selects the active modules and then
the second one called the communication
attention
that says how the different
how the different modules communicate
with each other those
are sort of the higher level modules
that control the flow of information of
the lower level modules
and now in the recurrent independent
mechanisms paper this as i understand is
just learned end to end
okay now this paper comes into action
and says
wait a minute shouldn't like if if we
have
the same environment but different tasks
okay so here you see
individual episodes and these individual
episodes are comprised
of a couple of time steps okay
now they say if we want
to learn these little modules such that
they share knowledge
like they learn the independent things
and they can be recombined
in different ways across the tasks
shouldn't we sort of when we learn the
individual modules yes
we do the what they call fast update we
do
the classic rl where we learn maybe
frame by frame or
from short sequences within an episode
okay so if you know the goal
then let's learn the little
pieces that make the goal happen but in
order to
learn to select the pieces you should
look across
different spans across different uh
episodes so that's what they call the
slow
update right here so they propose to
learn these meta parameters or what they
call them the communication
parameters in a slower fashion
feeding in longer episodes and here you
can see it even spans across
the different tasks and the idea here is
that
the these slower parameters they
consider
longer time spans they see multiple
tasks at the same time
and they learn how to select the
different modules
depending on the current
input the current task and yeah so by
seeing different variants of that
in single episodes they get to they get
to know the
differences and the commonalities
between tasks
now that is a high goal
so here my first problem is they call
these like
meta sequences and yes okay they are
meta sequences but i disagree
that that is meta learning so what they
ultimately do is
here is algorithm one
so they randomly initialize the
parameters of
the uh they randomly initialize the
parameters
of the attention units and here the
um the little mechanism
units okay they randomly slice them
by the way the also the the policy
parameters are part of the
the meta unit parameters and the value
head parameters are then part of the
attention parameters they're not
actually part of these modules but
they're learned
also on different time scales okay so
the policy is
learned fast and the value is learned
slow
um that's just because
feelings so
well not done we sample a batch a batch
of tasks
and then for each task we sample a
trajectory
and then we learn the
modules the mechanisms in the fashion
right we
keep the attention parameters constant
that doesn't mean we always select the
same module the attention parameters
being constant means that
the way the queries and the keys are
generated from the input
that remains fixed um but
it's still going to be differently
selected modules from from
from time to time it's just that the way
in which we select
which ones are active aren't updated
from time step to time step
and keeping that fixed we learn the
individual little things
we learn the mechanisms in a very
classic fashion
so you can see right here these are
individual episodes
okay the loss function is the proximal
policy optimization
loss a very classic with like an entropy
term and so on they have it somewhere
here
so this is a very classic ppo loss um
this thing right here you have this clip
loss
for the policy you can see here is the
um
so here is you have the probability
ratio which is sort of like the the
policy
uh parameter this is the current policy
this is the
old policy
and then you have the value function
loss and then you have an entropy
parameter
loss so quite a standard loss for
reinforcement learning and you learn
that from individual
episodes and you update the parameters
of the mechanisms
as we said right so you only
activate the modules that are currently
um that are selected by the attention
and the back propagation would reflect
that
in then in the second step you sample
again trajectories
from tasks but then instead of keeping
the tasks and the episodes separate
you now concatenate all of them into
what they call meta
sequences and then you update your
attention parameters
using those meta sequences while keeping
the
mechanisms constant right so in the
first step
you learn you know given sort of the
activation policy of the mechanisms how
should the mechanisms
behave in order to achieve good reward
right so
how you know how they're selected
remains constant
so they they just get selected and then
they're
they're meant to maximize the reward
and so any any mechanism here you know
when they're selected they're just being
like okay
what do i need to do to solve the
current problem
and if they are selected in a consistent
mechanism
that will cause them to specialize right
if one is always
selected when the the orange thing is in
the input
it will sort of start to specialize in
these kinds of tasks
and in the other step the mechanisms are
kept constant so you have the little sub
modules
that can achieve or can can can do
certain
subtasks and now you're trying to select
the best ones of them so you're trying
to train the attention mechanism
how do you facilitate the selection and
communication between the
these given fixed mechanisms such that
the reward is the highest
so in this two-step fashion the
little mechanisms get better at the
tasks they're tasked with
which causes them to to specialize if
they're selected correctly and then
the selection itself is updated which
in turn makes the learning signal for
the mechanisms better
and then better mechanisms make the
learning signal for the selection better
and so on you can imagine that this
two-step process
is sort of you know kind of uh
swinging itself up bootstrapping itself
up
to very very good interlocking pieces
of things okay in the experiments that
looks
fairly promising um you can see often
see so they
probably you can't see so the blue one
is vanilla
which is sort of an lstm controller the
green ones is the recurrent
independent mechanism one while the red
one and i don't have red here i have
orange
red one is this new uh two-step approach
it's not always the case and
reinforcement learning is quite tricky
but this being largely the same authors
i guess
they do at least have a good comparison
to recurrent independent mechanisms
though i have to say this is measured in
frames so how many frames did you
consume
and that is an important thing because
sample efficiency is important
but also given how complicated this
scheme is i wonder
if this is slower or faster
than just training both things at the
same time like the recurrent independent
mechanisms did
okay so again the difference between
this and the last paper is simply that
they
they propose this two-step process where
you have
one step here and another
step here instead of learning these two
things
jointly and they do so deliberately in
environments where you have multiple
tasks given
so you know like it's another lesson in
hey
you know you need to evaluate on the
things where you are really really
meant for to be good at and you need to
evaluate in the quantity
that you're meant to be good at i'm not
sure if time
here would show the same plots if you
had like in the x-axis time or
computation or anything like this it
might very well be
um so they demonstrate
that they do you know a lot of uh
have a lot of success with this they
demonstrate that if they train
on let's say small environments that
they call difficult environments
uh that the metterims that's their
system the modular is the
old paper and vanilla is the base
implementation
they demonstrate that even though
they all get to fairly good success rate
and reward
on the difficult problems if you make it
zero shot
more difficult so you increase the size
of the problem with with
without ever having trained on the
bigger problem so you make that room a
lot bigger
for finding the key the these meta what
they call meta
rims they generalize a lot better
than the other ones right you can see
right here the other ones
largely fail and they claim their system
um generalizes a lot better
so reinforcement learning experimental
results
are very very tricky right you can you
you've already seen sort of the
just the the bars here the error bars up
here
and that's after a long probably
experimentation maybe
and also selecting the right metrics and
so on
here we don't even get bars and
here it's uh it's quite tricky because
not only do for example the vanilla ones
generalize worse they also start at a
worse point
right so they they start at much less
reward and maybe that's responsible
for them not generalizing so well if you
were to actually push
like 0.95 to 0.97 doesn't see much
but if you look it's like almost
half the error right so here like
if the maximum reward is one then this
gets
you know five less than the maximum
reward and this only gets three less
this is
quite a reduction maybe that's the
reason why at
zero shot transfers to the more
difficult environment
also here the the modular ones which you
have to remember is the exact same
architecture as the metal earned ones
they don't even have a good success in
these tasks so the hypothesis of this
paper here is that
if you learn all these things at the
same time
you will still be subject to
catastrophic forgetting
in these environments where you have
multiple tasks
right by learning the
high level parameters in a slower way in
a
first of all in an independent way
second of all
in a um
in a way where they see a longer
sequences
of things and i do believe
also and this is also a bit unclear i
also do believe they do
um less update steps maybe not
no i think that it's just that their
their
steps that they consider the time steps
they consider
are four times more than the time steps
that
the individual that the learning here
considers so line six
has some number of steps uh
n number of steps and
line nine here considers four times n
the number of steps okay so they
consider longer time scales
if you want some other numbers uh they
always have
five of these so they always have
five which is what they call little n
and of the five there are always k
equals three active
so there are always three of five things
active
at any given point in time and that is
a bit of a different problem i have here
uh
you know to their contribution
is let's learn these higher level
parameter
independently and in a more slow fashion
that's the contribution right not the
recurrent independent mechanisms
the the separation now
i would expect there to be a lot more
investigation
into what exactly this separation
and slower learning is doing they do
have
some ablations right here but
not many most ablations are about the
recurrent independent mechanisms itself
so for example here
they compare k equals three
and two and they show look across the
episode
different modules become active
as time progresses which gives you an
indication that yes in fact the
different modules do specialize in
different things
which is cool right that is not a
property of this separation that's a
property of recurrent independent
mechanisms
and here again they the ablation they do
here
is different k so different number of
sub modules
being active and you can see that
if all the modules are active all the
time you have the pink curve which is
quite bad and if only some modules
are active here like k equals three you
get a much better performance
now i would expect that
that you actually try to go to k equals
1 or something like this
to show maybe there's an optimal subset
and so on but
again this is a property of recurrent
independent mechanisms
only here where they say shorter
meta episode
so here they say what if we do the same
thing that works well
but we make this meta episode shorter
and then you can see that the curve here
it also it sort of follows the
trajectory of the
of the the worst um baseline
now that is one thing right where they
make they don't say
how much shorter they make it they just
say we make it shorter and that hurts
i mean okay here
they analyze the value function which is
cool you can sort of see that the value
function reacts to
different things in the environment
again that is not
a that is not a
property of what they're doing um
and here choice of attention this is
ablation choice of attention parameters
as slow parameters
okay so they say now
let's do a different thing let's
actually flip let's learn the attention
parameters in a fast way
and the meta parameters in oh sorry the
mechanism parameters in a slow way and
that's what they call
meta flip and here they show
um they show that that performs
worse okay so the the top one here
is the meta what they propose
and the bottom one here is the
flipped one where they learn uh
the other parameters slow and the
attention parameters fast
and again okay that's a that's a thing
right but it's it's not so much worse
honestly like and at some point they say
well it's
somewhat worse and in the texts and they
say that is
uh did not perform very well
right here this did not perform very
well and
you know i disagree a bit like it
performed
okay like it's certainly better than the
than the vanilla one
it looks like it maybe at the same as
the vanilla one
it doesn't seem super duper bad
and i just don't think this is
since this paper is about adding this
thing the addition of this thing
and the sort of um you know
how much that contributes and what
exactly of the thing
makes the algorithm stronger i don't
think that's explored enough in this
paper i think too much space is wasted
on exploring like the value function
and which modules are active which we
already know
from the recurrent independent
mechanisms right
there are in fact two things going on
right there is the slowness
there is the fact of hey let's learn one
set of parameters more slowly than
another set of parameters
that's one thing and the other thing is
hey let's decouple
learning the two parameters now the
decoupling actually is what
i think makes it not meta this is simply
decoupling this is not meta learning
as far as i'm concerned this is not
learning to learn or anything like this
it's simply that we have two different
things and we learn them at two
different times
this is very much like you know in the
beginning of gans
you have whatever your generator
and your discriminator and
here and here you have your your data
set
and here you have your binary
classification
and here you have your latent vector
okay these
this is a basic drawing of a gan and
um what people used to do at least at
the beginning before we realized how we
can stabilize gun training
is they did these independently they
said
i'm going to do one step learning the
discriminator
and then i'm going to do another step
learning the generator
instead of updating them both at the
same time and
at the beginning we even did things like
hey let's learn the generator
for five steps and let's learn the
discriminator only for
one step once we get to the
discriminator so
it is exactly the same thing it was that
was not met to learning
this is simply the fact that if you have
a system
where the parameters are sort of
entangled with each other like the
discriminator
depends on the output of another system
which itself has parameters if you
change
everything at the same time that can get
you
into trouble that can get you into
instability
and therefore it might be a good idea to
separate
these and if one system is sort of
stronger than the other system
it might also be effective to learn
these at different
time scales there's nothing sort of to
do with metallurgy and it's two
different things
right this time scale and the separation
are two different
things and yeah these are not
entangled here and they they also
compare with what they call slow
lr they say well in order to
compare what we can also do is we can
simply
learn the parameters of the attention
and the mechanisms at the same time but
we can give
the um we can give the
attention simply a lower
learning rate like we divide
the instead of dividing the number of
steps before we divide the learning rate
by four
and they stay show that doesn't work and
i mean it's not a surprise that doesn't
work that
is absolutely not the same thing right
it's
and i'm not even sure what it's supposed
to show i guess it's supposed to show
that
um that you need the
separation instead so the slowness
itself
isn't a thing but i don't think you
even if the slowness was a thing it it
is not that you can
simply replace the number of steps by a
smaller
learning rate
yeah in any case but it is it is at
least like uh
some kind of experiment that that shows
something about the system
right what i would expect from an
experiment
like this is yeah here again like what
the modules are learning
which is cool like it's cool that you
show look this module is learning this
this one is active when that happens and
so on
and we can ablate the winner modules so
what they do is they take the modules
that are selected and then you randomly
drop
out some of them and they discover well
the more we drop
out the less well it works wow
but there's no investigation into okay
what is the effect
of learning one thing more slowly how
much is the effect can we modulate that
can we set the number of
slow steps equal to 5 to 6 to 10 to 20.
um you know can we can we
discuss how long these meta episodes
need to be like here it's just like
shorter okay but there's no indication
like how long do they need to be
what's a good length um then give us
give us like the time penalty that we
incur here not only the frames
right what's what's the time penalty
might there be
already something good about simply
separating the updates
uh you know like all of this kind of
stuff
is not really uh
explored in this paper so again
there is really cool parts about this
paper
it makes sense to separate these two
because you have an interdependent
system reinforcement learning is brutal
enough already
and it really seems to help against this
catastrophic forgetting
however for the fact that this paper
simply adds this two-step
approach i don't think it does enough to
show
what they're doing and to show the
reasons of
why what they're doing works works and
also i object to this being called meta
learning
so that is my opinion uh please
tell me your opinion this was a bit more
ranty than i usually do but i hope
you're still here
and i'll see you next time bye